Louis again thank you so much for the
invite great party
of course Garrett it's so much fun to
mingle with everyone outside of work
really had a good turnout this year
definitely
do you mind tending the grill for a bit
I think I see Rachel trying to leave hey
Rach you look like you're trying to
escape dare this is the worst BB q I
have ever been to
worse than Kenny McMillan high school
when you got superglue to that floating
rap is worse and Kenny mcnutt's was like
the worst day of my life you try to
change schools after no Garrity thinking
about transferring before those fart was
when you were trying to get into a pool
and people kept shoving you back here
here's the plan I kicked the grill over
starting a fire creating like a mass
evacuation oh that's a horrible but we
need to come up with like a signal what
signal why no I'm not giving you
anything or we'll make like a code word
what it'll be I uh I got it the code
word is pierce brosnan no code words bro
you said and I quote this is going to be
the Coachella of office party I said
quote it will be a pretty fun BB yeah
but I try to rewrite everything that you
say in my head while you're talking to
MIT to make it more interesting so I'm
not just like constantly bored to death
by everything you're say well if this is
Coachella
then I'm in the Samsun hospitality
pavilion handing out free bottles of
water and USB key to proving to Lewis
then I'm a team player longer because
one drinking vitamin waters and crushing
kind bars getting shuttled in my VIP
golf cart to the Sahara Chet Lewis stops
traffic gets in my car and tells me a
15-minute story about the time that he
saw a bird you listen to one of Lewis's
bird stories oh it's not a story Garrett
looking at something is not a story I
don't see I really appreciate that you
just earned me huge points oh look at
this
describe for me what you see on the
grill right now some nice razor burn
ballpark Frank's today look completely
disgusting it's not that bad Quinn okay
it's pretty bad oh great here comes your
ex hey shel hello Garrett platonic
coworker this party is terrible I don't
know how much more I can take I know if
I pass out from boredom you may have to
pull up the defibrillators uh-huh
Kari you're always so funny can you put
my diet coke for me oh sure yeah I can
get that no no Gary do not touch that
can Quinn it's just another manipulation
technique you can't have it both ways
she'll you dumped him Ben please throw a
guy back all open the soda thanks Quinn
oh that was really hard it has been
really hard the doctor says that if
keep up my physical therapy I'll get my
motor skills back soon it'll be like I
never had that stroke stroke stroke
it was nothing just a minor stroke the
lifeguard pulled me out just in time
shell shell I had no idea there's a
lifeguard you want to talk about it I'm
right here
actually going to leave goodbye Garret
she's so brave yet I'm not brave enough
to win her back well she just gave me a
great idea
let's tell Lewis that my aunt had a
medical emergency so we can both go oh
I'm back brought you guys some beers a
sweet Bud Light Lime really refreshing
oh thanks these must be super rare I've
literally never seen anyone drink one
can you believe that both Rachel and
Sandy had family medical emergencies
really getting a lot of the lime Jason
don't climb that fence that goes out to
the driveway I'm faster he's looking
over where you parked your cars Oh Derek
it's a jailbreak the time is now well we
got to make our move all you're gonna do
Gary's just say the code word Oh guys
since it looks like it's just us left I
can finally tell you the Blue Jays story
Bob please no I think you already told
us about the bird no this was a
different bird oh my god this is my
nightmare this beautiful blue jay I've
ever seen
was tweeting outside my office one day I
thought to myself is that a bird it
sounds like a bird but then I hears a
lot Brosnan what season is it right now
oh my god look Lois look look it's a
bird
oh is it perched or influenza I really
thought that was gonna be bigger
hey guys I'm printing an apology collage
for my boss I'm looking for some sick
photos of birds you know i cute birds
but also birds that say that like I'm a
team player post a link in the comments
thanks